clock time is fine but psychological
time is when future takes over your mind
and your entire thought patterns are
geared only towards future for many
years before I wrote the power of now
and it became successful I was basically
a failure many people spent their lives
in a state of almost permanent
dissatisfaction if you are habitually
and frequently unhappy you believe that
it has a purpose
he's a german-born resident of Canada
best known as being the author of the
book the power of now in 2008 a New York
Times writer called him the most popular
spiritual author in the United States
his books have sold almost 10 million
copies across North America
he's Eckhart Tolle and here is my take
on his top 10 rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips
also as eckers talking if he says
something that really resonates with you
try to copy down to the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and learn as well so
people any people have this idea I want
to achieve something great or be
somebody great and they neglect the step
that leads to greatness they don't honor
this step at this moment because they
have this idea of some future moment
where they're going to be great right
some people believe I'm doing great work
I mean I am because the consciousness is
moving through this form I don't feel
personally responsible for what I do is
such but even there it is small steps
when the writing happens is a notepad
and a pen unless the present moment and
this is stillness very small is not some
idea I'm going to create a work that's
going to change everybody's
consciousness no I'm just true to this
moment what is this moment requires
it's a blank piece of sheet of paper and
a pen and the stillness it's a small
thing it's all a sequence of very small
moments and by being true to this small
moment something great arises talking
about past and future and excessive
emphasis on past and few
in your life yes of course you need to
have it there's nothing wrong with
having a certain intention of what you
want to achieve take steps to Ward's it
it's a it's part of living here in this
dimension you can't just say I'm never
going to plan anything anymore just take
life as it comes
well some people try to do that but
they're not that happy either after a
while so then your life will get very
diffused and so to have an intention to
have to make a plan perfectly fine what
you either a short-term plan like are
going to meet you tomorrow at 4 o'clock
how would you ever meet anybody if we
didn't have time and and future in a
practical level of course it's needed
the question is whether future takes
over your mind being able to use it for
practical purposes it will cause great
but I call it clock time is fine but
psychological time is when the future
takes over your mind and your entire
soul patterns are geared only towards
future and you treat the present moment
as either just a means to an end because
enables you to get to the next one
you're always reaching out so to speak
internally to the next yet never quite
here always looking for some fulfillment
there so you can never embrace the
fullness of now or you make them now
into even an enemy some people are
always unhappy you perhaps we all know
some one or two people like that 3 ha ha
ha we all who are wherever they are
they're complaining is never quite right
wherever they are or whoever they are
ways after a little while they're very
uncomfortable again there should be
somewhere else you know the bumper
sticker that you see in some cars in
various versions of it says I'd rather
be golfing and then another one says I'd
rather be fishing I'd rather be this I'd
rather be there when I visited the the
spiritual teacher Ram Dass who lives in
Hawaii
he has a bumper sticker on about Ram
Dass was the person who in the 70s wrote
the book be here now
anyway he has a bumper sticker on his
car that says I'd rather be here now so
and and then you realize you can
actually you can still pursue whatever
an intention where you want to get to a
plan I called it it's a bit like a
journey your life is a journey you're
going you know you want to go from here
to there whether you're going to get
there we don't know maybe on the way
you'll branch out to somewhere else but
at least you have a certain direction
it's good to have some direction in your
life but while you are traveling if the
that your destination takes up most of
your attention and you're continuously
focusing on there you miss all the
journey really you can't enjoy the
journey anymore and most of your life is
the journey the arriving is relatively
rare the wedding ah add a few more
graduation haha but so those moments are
not that fine feel between so the rest
is the journey and if you can't enjoy
the journey which means the step you are
taking at this moment it's really the
most important thing yes of course you
know you're going that way but this step
is still to be enjoyed because that's
ultimately your whole life consists of
the step you are taking at this moment
there is never anything else for many
years before I wrote the power of now
and it became successful I was basically
a failure in the eyes of the world so
he's already almost 50 and what has he
achieved my mum said you have thrown
away your life you had so many
possibilities in your life you walked
out of graduate school in Cambridge why
did you walk out of there you my mum and
many other people said this person has
failed in life he has no job he has no
insurance policies nothing
no pension plan just almost nothing in
the bank failure and then a few years
later people bought the power of now and
became
a best-seller or a big success okay if I
had arrived my identity at that time
from what the world was telling me or my
mind would have told me if I have been
listening to my mind I would have been
very unhappy and I didn't know I was
fine because my identity wasn't derived
from that anymore
and fortunately even when in the eyes of
the world I suddenly became a success I
don't want to derive my identity from
that it's it's a cheap substitute for
who I really am so I'm not I don't see I
don't arrive but the satisfaction it
comes is the satisfaction that the work
that's happening the teaching that's
happening is transforming people's lives
that's very satisfying I don't get any
personal satisfaction though because
it's not I don't feel it as this
separate me produced it now it's very
easy to mistake an impulse that comes to
you for some deeper answer that comes
out of the stillness in so in any
decision-making process you have
basically two factors well most people
only have you have the information
that's available to you and so make sure
that you you have the information that
of all the facts that you need sometimes
before making a decision you may have a
few a number of facts and sometimes
these facts may not be sufficient so
then you go within and see what
questions can you can ask in order to
elicit more facts or information from
whoever's capable of giving to you that
information this I'm talking very
general terms whether you're in business
or wherever you are or some personal
decision that you need to arrive at may
on one
facts are need to be looked at what is
the situation and sometimes the facts
are not clear enough or you are not
enough facts and you become stale and
see what questions you can ask somebody
may be able to supply more detailed
facts but you know order to ask the
right question you already need a moment
of stillness so this you may not
immediately get an answer through
stillness the first step as you become
alert and still is another question what
a very important thing in decision
making process is not to come up with a
decision but to ask the right question
that can elicit what you need in order
to arrive at a decision and in order to
ask the right question there needs to be
that
alert stillness for a moment and in that
alert stillness you kind of listen
within and then a question comes this is
I often when somebody they call me and
say we've had this or that offer
somebody wants you to do this somebody
wants you to do that interview somebody
wants to do that and very often I don't
immediately say yes or no I usually come
up with a few questions
what in addition to the information that
they gave me well what about that and
letting that end and say oh okay I'll
get back to you I'll find out then they
call again then I know a bit more and
sometimes on the basis of the factual
information you already know whether you
want to do it or not
you more easily know that you don't want
to do it just by looking at the facts
many people spend their lives in a state
of almost permanent dissatisfaction
right unfortunately so they may be
looking for some purpose or they may
have given up hope that there is some
purpose for them and they're just
surviving or making a living or caught
up in the doing hold up in the doing
in the stress of it right and so usually
when we talk about purpose when people
talk about purpose they think of purpose
in terms of future where am I going
Monty my supposed to do what's the
direction I'm going what is my goal the
goal that I want to achieve and that of
course is that it has its place but I
call that the outer purpose more
fundamental than the outer purpose is
what most people usually overlooked and
that is the realization that what
matters most is finding your inner
purpose so inner purpose is aligning
your life fully with the present moment
so that you are no longer out of
alignment with the present moment which
leads to the state of dissatisfaction
that we talked about it is the reality
for many people so you have to go
further or beyond the state of
dissatisfaction that is so many people's
reality right but you cannot go beyond
the state of dissatisfaction through
some future goal that says one day I
would like to be in a state of
fulfillment or satisfaction no you have
to enter the state of fulfillment and
satisfaction by becoming one internally
with the present moment in the your
purpose then your inner purpose is that
alignment with where you are right now
to be totally where you are and whatever
you are doing even if it doesn't look
like your life purpose for that you buy
for the next 30 years right whatever you
are doing now to be total enjoying it
and what no matter what it is to be true
to life by being true to this moment
it's not that difficult really to step
out of the stream of thinking through
one way of course is meditation it's the
traditional approach is you have certain
periods of time once or twice a day when
you sit down close your eyes and instead
of involuntarily
being
on into the continuous stream of
thinking you usually in with meditation
you have a technique or message you
focus your attention on one thing which
could be a mantra that you preach it
could be your breathing it's a very
ancient meditation it could be the inner
feeling in your body the sense of
aliveness that pervade pervades your
body in other words you take attention
away from thinking and that's already a
great realization that you are able you
have actually have a choice of directing
attention you don't have to go to you
don't have to go with your attention all
the time where the habitual thought
patterns want you to go the a bit your
thought returns want your attention
every time every thought says I may take
give me your attention follow me they go
this way and another negative thought
and another one and another one
yes compassion for yourself of course is
as important as compassion for others
when you often I get asked questions
like people who did something that they
now realize realize was deeply wrong in
the past sometimes people ask questions
about they brought up their children in
a way that they now realize was not very
conscious and so that they may have
caused suffering to their children or
other people find they have caused
suffering to loved ones and they now
realize that what they did was wrong and
again I say this is an example where you
need to be compassionate with yourself
because nobody woman being can act
beyond their level of consciousness so
that was your level of consciousness at
the time and you could not go beyond
that and again here to make demands upon
yourself up to a point it might be a
good thing to butcher if you as long as
you enjoy it it's a wonderful thing when
the enjoyment of what you're doing is
lost then you have to be careful because
there you have to come to a stop and say
okay this is
something here that's not right because
I'm no longer enjoying what I'm doing a
lot of so-called unhappiness is also a
childish way of trying to change things
by being as unhappy as you can about
them and the underlying unconscious or
semi-conscious assumption is if I'm
really unhappy somebody perhaps God is
going to do something about it or I'm
going to prove him wrong I'm going to
show him how dreadful it is and then
finally this is an unconscious
assumption behind the unhappiness
because you believe if you are
habitually and frequently unhappy you
believe that it has a purpose
it's an underlying assumption perhaps
you wouldn't verbalize it in that way
but you believe that it it's it works
for you because it doesn't but things
are going to change but just need to be
really unhappy so that God finally evens
you don't believe in God this this can
still be the mechanism the underlying
unconscious assumption behind it
it's something's going to happen and of
course the opposite is true because the
more happy are with something the more
you're stuck in the situation how you do
what you do is more important than what
you do you could have a you could have a
stores serving customers with this or
that which perhaps would not be regarded
as a very important job and yet if that
is done with a quality of presence where
every customer comes into your store you
give this person you're just an example
your fullest attention you appreciate
him or her as a human being you see how
you can best serve him or her in the
present moment that is quality and then
you would be improving everybody who
comes into contact with you would
somehow experience a small lifting in
their being in consciousness and so that
you could create a even a person with a
relatively in relatively simple
Bob could contribute in that way to
creating a better world
you don't become good by trying to be
good but by finding the goodness that is
already within you and allowing that
goodness to emerge but it can only
emerge if something fundamental changes
in your state of consciousness yes so
what that means if if nothing changes in
your state of consciousness the ego has
many ideas it says I want to be a
spiritual person mm-hmm I want to be
recognized as a spiritual person I want
to be more spiritual than all these
people and I'm definitely more spiritual
than you so the ego has all kinds of
ideas of what it wants to be it might
even say yes I want to be good because
it wants to have a better image of
itself but on that level but the the
essential dysfunction of the ego is
still operating so this is why we have
the phrase the road to hell is paved
with good intentions because no matter
how good your intentions are when you
are still trapped in the ego it will
always take you into conflict eventually
so you have to go deeper beyond the
realm of opposites where there's good
and bad and preached a place within
yourself that is unconditioned that is
what I sometimes call the formless
Express beautifully in the Old Testament
in the little saying be still and know
that I am God that is and that's in the
Old Testament it contains the entire
wisdom of religion in those few words be
still
meaning go to that place where the mind
is no longer operating where there's
you're just conscious without thinking
and that is the level where the eternal
resides
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because live now oh six
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you I'm going to
profile next leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Eckerd's
top ten rules had the biggest impact on
you and why what change you're going to
make after watching this video what
inspiration came to you after watching
these clips leave in the comments below
and I will join in the discussion
finally I want to give a quick shout out
to Jay grind Jay thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book it really means
a lot to me those are you watching if
you want your chance at a shout out in a
future video make sure to pick up a copy
of the book and email in your receipts
so we can keep track and send you the
bonuses too thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
then allotment is required to truly
truly perceive things and immediately
things become more life and less
problematic when you're going to
senseless efforts because the
problematic dimension is in the head and
you got your sensation suddenly you have
into the present moment and in the
present moment problems disappear isn't
that strange
so the mind says well I still have them
yeah when you start thinking about them
you have them again but when you're not
thinking about them you have no problems
now some of you will argue with that but
let me explain you have situations in
your life that can be challenging and
you have to deal with these situations
but the only place where you can deal
with the challenging situations is in
the present moment and dealing with the
challenging situation in the present
moment is not a problem you're dealing
with the challenging situation you're
facing it you're looking at it and that
looking is important what I call looking
really is paying putting your attention
on it which is the power of
consciousness and while you're looking
you're not thinking every person who is
achieved mastery in any field knows what
I mean by looking because they think
that absolute presence and then that
person does what he or she does is it
flow it it flows from that presence so
you look there's no problem problem is
when you dwell mentally on something
that will happen could happen might
happen a problem that's something I have
to face next week but not now and you're
totally absorbed in that it's problem an
interesting thing I may have even
written that in the path now if you
think you have problems
ask yourself what problem do I have at
this moment but this moment really means
this moment and then you have to go
well I've got um my wife my ex-wife is
suing me I'm about to lose my home
person close to me is ill I might lose
my job I have to look for a new job
okay what problem do you have at this
moment your breathing feeling the
aliveness in the body looking around
well well at this moment I don't
actually have a problem you have to then
admit if you really go into the present
moment it the mob the problem cannot
survive in the present moment it's an
amazing realization doesn't mean that
you no longer deal with what you need to
deal with you deal with it when the
moment comes more effectively when you
don't waste your life energy in the
mental realm of creating problems that
you cannot be dealt with at this moment
and if you wake up in the middle of the
night thinking about your problems and
what you can do about them it's
extremely unlikely that you find any
solution by worrying at 4 o'clock in the
morning about it but if you came still
at 4 o'clock in the morning and wake up
and go into the inner energy field of
the body rather than thinking about your
problems in other words leave the
dimension of problems come deeply into
the present moment then perhaps the next
morning when you wake up you sumsy oh I
know what I have to do now I know how
can deal with it now and the right cause
of action happens because you've gone
there but not through the problem making
faculty in the human mind so again
coming back to your question when things
are when you're not yet not being
silenced practice it and then when you
are being challenged by little things
that goes wrong so to speak in daily
life tends to happen you might have
noticed things don't always go according
to your expectation
sometimes you miss the bus or something
you miss the plane or something else
goes wrong it tends to happen actually
quite a lot it seems to be part of the
life that's by the way it's the reason
why people go to see movies because the
substructure of every movie that you see
we could call it it applies to virtually
every movie you see if you can examine
any movie you see what actually happens
in the movie it's like I can describe
every movie to you in three words
something goes wrong because there
wouldn't be a movie otherwise nothing
what's happened nobody would evolve
everything would be dead but in your own
life you complain so you go you'd see
movies to see something go wrong but
when it happens in your own life you
complain not you personally you've
transcended it perhaps already but so
the strange thing is it's things are not
meant not to go wrong going wrong is
part of the totality of how life
experiences itself if things didn't go
wrong would be very uninteresting and
nobody would evolve because people only
evolved through the challenges that they
encounter and in a good movie the
protagonist or the character changes as
he or she faces the probe that which
goes wrong in the movie in a bad movie
so to speak the character does not go
through any changes the that which goes
wrong is only solved on an external
level the in the end the bad guy is
killed and that's the end of the movie
but nothing else happens
so something going wrong is part of how
life experiences itself and again you
can then bring awareness to that so that
you don't always fall into reactivity
when something goes wrong but you
immediately align
it